[Musique]
voilà mes adieux à la télévision
alors est-ce que je suis un personnage
de la casa n'ai pas peur
je vous laisse réfléchir oui ou non casa
des appels ou
pakasa des papes elle
avec la barbe c'est chic en plus
paris xième arrondissement il est 23
heures romain et ses amis semblent
passer une soirée à peu près normale
pourtant sur la table que des alcools
forts l'ambition est claire s'alcooliser
toute la nuit ces jeunes feront aussi ce
qu'on appelle du binge drinking ou
encore de l'aquaplaning des idées
toujours plus étonnantes qui peuvent
parfois rend le travail fastidieux pour
les forces de l'ordre
bonne année à tous mais petit canard
c'est pour vous dire que c'est une super
année la saison 6 va bientôt arriver ça
va être le bordel les enfants je vous
embrasse les faux ouaddou vide vide
plein suis celui qui est plein hyper
facile
c'est le cas nous c'est vrai ça va aller
verser non non tu regardes tu regardes
pas bien quoi vide vide plein allez on
refait
[Musique]
reste on attend un truc à temps
à cause de
séismes ou si les maquereaux
[Musique]
oui quel sens figuré
le
[Musique]
times the sun michael